2016 isn't just the year we get  civilization 6 it's also the series 25th  anniversary and publisher 2k is  celebrating in style I'm Tony and this  is your limited edition gamespot news  update sip sixes 25th anniversary  edition is only coming to pc via select  retailers such as Amazon the $90 bundle  includes custom packaging a hardcover  artbook and a commemorative coin set  plus everything in the digital deluxe  version of the game like new maps and  leaders if that interests you act  quickly only 20,000 units are being made  the civilization series has sold over 35  million worldwide so expect these to go  fast civilization 6 comes to pc mac and  linux on october 21st pre-ordering the  game gets you the aztecs civilization  pack which 2k has stated will become  free for everyone in January 2017 we've  got plenty of civ 6 coverage at gamespot  so head on over to check out tons of  gameplay and to keep up with all the  latest strategy news you're already in  the right place